ouais la sodomie la fellation même entre
époux euh tout va les fermer point c'est
interdit
à l'origine moi je fais pas mal de
droits d'auteur je fais pour des
producteurs de films porno entre autres
pour des éditeurs de lit très sérieux
mais il y a toujours un petit moment où
bon il y a une scène un peu plus
déshabillée qui se pose la question
qu'est-ce que je risque qu'est-ce que je
fais est-ce que je peux est-ce que je
peux pas et puis moi quand je réfléchis
là-dessus je me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'on
a le droit de dire et puis et puis voilà
bah de fil en aiguille on remonte et les
mecs qui font du porno ils viennent te
montrer leur film pour savoir ce que ce
que tu en penses
visionner des cassettes ouais entre
autres qu'est-ce qui est permis que
c'est interdit en France aujourd'hui
dans un film porno par exemple
la pédophilie c'est relativement
interdit quand même très interdit à
Marseille il y a pas grand chose
d'interdit
tu permets
c'est-à-dire dans un film porno on peut
avoir une on peut toujours on peut
toujours se ramasser une plainte d'une
société de protection des animaux enfin
Maurice que pas grand chose quand même
en pratique au Moyen-Âge on risque
beaucoup plus quand même on était le
soir qu'est-ce qu'on risquait au mieux
on pouvait être voler ah ouais alors ce
qui était marrant
le cochon ou l'âne ou la poule
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence c'était brûlé
avec ah ouais alors aujourd'hui c'est un
peu différent on envoie le type en
cabane au mieux enfin au pire plutôt
quant à l'animal non il va dans un
centre type expert
on a un peu changé on a distingué les
deux
mais par exemple dans un film porno si
on voit un type qui fait l'amour avec un
animal ou une femme tellement avec un
animal dans le critère c'est est-ce que
l'animal souffre ou non
c'est pas est-ce que c'est bien ou pas
bien
est-ce que c'est bien ou pas c'est
est-ce que l'animal a mal ou non alors
j'ai tendance à croire que une poule A
plus d'embarrasses avoir mal qu'un âne
donc en fait
une poule ça serait moins autorisé
encore plus autorisé que Canal donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ou pas faire
en France donc par exemple l'amour en
public est-ce qu'on peut faire l'amour
en public non on peut toujours pas faire
l'amour au public pourquoi pourquoi
parce que il y a une belle loi qui
avance appelée l'outrage publique elle a
pudeur aujourd'hui ça s'appelle
exhibition sexuelle ça se cache un peu
moins sous la terminologie comme ça sous
le vocabulaire enfin globalement quand
même on risque toujours un an de prison
et puis je crois jusqu'à 1 million
fondament ah oui ça peut coûter
et dis-moi et sadomaso c'est autorisé ça
donne c'est autorisé jusqu'à ce que le
partenaire porte plainte pour violence
quand même d'accord
exemple bon puis je te fouette je te
fouette je te fouette et puis après tu
as mal et tu m'en veux et ben demain je
peux porter plainte et puis même si dans
l'après-midi
et puis et puis bah c'est jusqu'à trois
ans mille francs donc c'est toléré tant
qu'il y en a pas un qui qui a mal en
gros dans le mariage qu'est-ce qui est
autorisé la fellation par exemple une
femme peut pas se plaindre d'être
obligée de faire des fellations à son
mari par exemple
il y a un paradoxe qui existe entre le
devoir conjugal c'est à dire
l'obligation donc
de pratiquer le coït plus ou moins
régulièrement tu es obligé de le faire
il me saute plus donc je veux divorcer
leur a raison exactement elle peut
gagner son pour faute mais en revanche
on peut pas non plus aller trop loin
dans l'autre sens
le viol entre époux donc ça existe
depuis 90 les cryptos
donc il faut choisir la juste mesure
pas de sodomie
elle peut aller voir elle peut aller à
la police en disant mon mari veut me
[__] tous les soirs j'en ai marre
oui c'est généralement pas exactement
comme ça que ça se passe les cas qui
reviennent le plus fréquemment c'est
justement de la zoophilie c'est genre
Roger veut que je couche avec le berger
allemand et alors et ben alors là c'est
divorce pour faute
et est-ce qu'on a le droit de faire
l'amour avec un cadavre par exemple
ça dépend si la famille du cadavre porte
plainte généralement c'est pas le
cadavre lui-même qu'il fait
bien quand même atteinte au respect du
Honor et c'est la famille porte pas
plainte que c'est un cadavre disons
100 ans ça va mais ça peut aller quand
même jusqu'à atteindre ton respect du
homard à l'intégrité d'un cadavre c'est
pas jusqu'à 2 ans et 200000 francs
200000 francs seulement
c'est moins cher que l'autre et par
exemple coucher avec sa nièce
ah bon et si elle est majeure et pas de
souci si elle est majeurs il y a aucun
souci on a pas le droit de l'épouser
c'est tout ouais c'est tout
et par exemple est-ce que si on devient
transexuel après on peut attaquer le
toubib pour castration
oui c'est possible parce que le
consentement de la victime ça joue pas
en droit pénal donc on peut très bien
vouloir quelque chose qui fait mal et le
lendemain porter plainte contre celui à
qui on l'a demandé donc en théorie on
peut toujours ça m'étendre quand même
qu'un magistrat condamne aujourd'hui
pour pour ce genre d'opération
sinon par exemple si on est marié avec
une [__] est-ce qu'on peut être accusé
de proxénétisme ah ouais là c'est même
régulier et puis il vaut mieux pas être
au chômage ah bon pourquoi ah bah là
c'est proximité à fond quand même c'est
le principe même c'est de vivre avec
quelqu'un qui touche des revenus la
prostitution
en plus on peut pas prouver soi-même ses
propres revenus on n'est pas très bien
donc qu'est-ce donc en France
aujourd'hui en France aujourd'hui une
[__] n'a pas le droit une prostituée
pour parler clairement
on a le droit de rien elle a pas le
droit d'être mariée elle a pas le droit
de être concubine elle a le droit de à
peine dire bonjour à sa concierge et
même pas lui donner les étrennes
et c'est vrai qu'avant en France
présente avant 80
la sodomie n'était pas considéré comme
viol
jusqu'en 80 à peu près tout et n'importe
quoi n'était pas considéré comme viol le
viol c'était la pénétration de force
dans un rapport classique type vagin
pénis tout le reste c'était de
l'attentat à la pub heure c'est-à-dire
on risquait 10 fois moins depuis 80
n'importe quel endroit
ils ont un peu adapté modernisé
n'importe quel pénétration par n'importe
quoi dans un orifice point de force
c'est du viol et dis-moi ça doit être
terrible de voir des des vieux juristes
bedonnants avec des toit encore quand tu
parles de ça c'est plutôt agréable mais
quand tu dois voir des vieux juristes
parler de ça et des gros ventre et
dînettes en écailles un peu chaud sur le
dessus non ça doit être terrible non il
parle de cette très sérieusement fait
pour disserter sur ce genre de choses
non ils en parlent très sérieusement
c'est très drôle parce que souvent les
magistrats tournent autour du pot et ils
osent pas vraiment dire de quoi il
s'agit donc on dit il a été puni à cause
de ce qu'il a fait bah alors là pour
trouver dans le jugement de quoi
exactement mystère il y a des étages
avaient lieu aux États-Unis où la ou la
ou la sodomie est vraiment
très poux tout va les fermer
cette interdit même si la femme est
concentrée
[Musique]
alors là il fallait pas me demander la
carte géographique exactement mais
logiquement c'est dans les états un peu
plus au sud obligatoirement mais toi tu
dois avoir maintenant que tu as Facebook
un là le sexe et la loi tu dois
vachement de de gens qui viennent te
voir qui ont des douleurs qui sont et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu